u.s stocks just suffered their biggest
one-day decline since june of 2020.
here's why an inflation surprise tanked
the market
um
so this is uh from inside a dow slumped
3.9 percent smp 4.3 percent nasdaq
tumbled
5.2 percent investors also sold bonds
oil oil gold cryptocurrencies in
response to bleaker economic outlook the
frantic sell-off was sparked by the
release of u.s inflation data on tuesday
which showed that in august the cpi rose
by 0.1 percent
month on month compared with the
expectation 0.1 percent drop in contrast
euron your inflation came in at 8.3 from
8.5 in july from the 40-year high
of 9.1 in june faster month on month
inflation signaled to investors that the
fed was unlikely to curtail
its rate hikes anytime soon it also
fanned concerns that the central bank
would approve a bumper rate of 0.75
basis points over 100 100 basis points
uh in september meeting and interest
rates might peak at a higher level than
previously expected so down right now is
at what roughly 31 000 give or take
right i think it was at 30 something
yesterday right 31 hour 30. it's at 31
right okay it's at 31 right now how and
this goes to both of you guys how bad
can this thing get okay if you go to a
five year go to a five year click on the
five year and go up a little bit so
everybody can see it
five year low is take that out that
doesn't count because that's the fear of
covets on 19 one let's take that one out
that's a real number right there in 2019
22-4
and then if you go to the last one there
is 22-2 right that's only five years ago
so we can say 22 was the low in the last
five years and the high that we hit was
what 36 and change 36.5 something like
that okay
so how low can this thing go
uh from where it's at right now with
31.1 if we keep getting reports like the
one that came out a couple days ago how
low can this thing go
i'm over and under at 28.5
right now just looking at it i'm that's
my over and under right now what's your
watermark
what i found is
again we do a trendline about where we
think reasonable value is and where are
we in relation to that and that trend
line reflects uh earning you know where
the earnings growth are where's the
earnings relative to the gdp of the
country where it is relative to
cyclically adjusted earnings all those
kinds of things
those measures would say that we are
about uh
30 above trend line 20 to 30 somewhere
in there which might be consistent with
what you indicated there
and that
the the the problem and why i don't i
just don't know what exactly what to put
there with that answer to that question
is that when you get into a sell-off and
you get into any kind of a
crisis that's caused by a shock of some
kind and you often go well below a trend
line yep and
and i i i'm just trying to keep making
the points on several these asset
categories particularly
residential
real estate
commercial real estate to a degree a
little less but still and
and with stocks all of those are well
above their trend lines and are
vulnerable and could easily have those
kinds of 20 30 corrections can you go to
max go 10 years go to max and see if we
can do 10 years
uh
she's not letting you do 10 years
what is 10 years ago i'm so curious so
20 okay right there all right 13 000
10 years ago we're at third that was at
13th out and it went all the way up and
then the drop right there so it's been
so the economic expansion started when
go to 0.8
uh economics right after the crisis yeah
so from there look what's happened
it's just gone up and don't even look at
that kobe thing that's fake that's not
real that should be erased right because
that's just i mean the major dip no
that's not real that's fake that's still
when you know just fill it in it keeps
going so just keep going up that's not
that's not real so if you go back to go
to 1994
go to 1990 okay right there it's fine
1994. okay so what happens from 94 is
what 36 it goes up to what
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going it goes from go go
right there it goes up to 10-7 36 to
10-7 is what
yeah
okay but now look from 10-8
to go to 2007.
go back a little bit go back a little
bit go back a little bit pretty flat
it's flat for a decade
if you look at that that is flat for one
decade
and then all of a sudden boom it goes up
from 10 6 to how high does it go 13 or
15 no no right before that
yeah so 13 3 13 14 000 september of
seven and then it drops to how low right
after oh wait
7 700 and it goes from 7 700 and 0 9
remember that was 50 of that but this is
the part from 7 700 to 36 thousand
in 14 years i mean that
the gdp we haven't grown four times
we haven't grown five times
so
i don't know i'm not here you know this
this podcast changed a little bit people
right now are probably going having to
go to the bathroom but you know it it
might have a run on the bank yeah they
may be like they're at their job they
just dropped their phone at their job
and boss is tapping them on their back
and saying don't touch me johnny i'm an
important podcast with the ceo of wamu
that's right it's not a covet toilet
paper shortage anymore it's a market for
the future
but but all i'm saying is all i'm saying
is for something to grow that much okay
so from 11 000 to 36
okay
3.6 times 3.5 times have people's salary
increased 3.5 times in 14 years no
what was the average income in 2009 just
go look up the average income average
u.s median income in 2009 median not a
median income in 2009. let's actually
see it
meeting you come 2009 okay which is what
what does it say zoom in a little bit so
we can see it all right 51 000. fine
what is it mary household though that's
household fine go use that one use the
household same exact comparison bring it
today
so it was what household was what 50
yeah you can put an individual see what
happens
okay so 51 fine go to 2022
what does this say
yeah their income didn't go to 118.9
million
uh median right there hit that all right
what does this say 79.7
that's an increase of 40 percent that's
okay family income though it's important
that's a house which one's the household
yeah that's exactly what we're competing
comparing 59 to 79 is a 40 growth okay
38 growth fine
life around you you've gone up 3.6 this
isn't real guys this is fake
you just have to understand this is not
real
everything is financed it's not
sustainable so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]